yeah like I know but you know I'm young
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah just like it
was the time where I like you know I
like to sniff Coke hmm
while playing no no summertime feel me
so let me get this straight so during
but during during your basketball years
yeah
so during the summer off season you
would play with the coke correct yeah no
I mean at at 40
three
like I don't even really I don't even
really [ __ ] with no hard drugs now you
know what I'm saying
um
but why I'm 43. yeah I got so much [ __ ]
out there got this fat and all [ __ ] like
that hot so that that 15 minutes are
high what is it worth well that's what
my pain is like you got to keep doing it
yeah it's like if you don't have to but
you're gonna want to no right because
like you said it it doesn't last long so
if you do it and you're out and you're
out you're having a night yeah you're
gonna keep doing it [ __ ] if it's around
what year how far into your career did
you start [ __ ] with Coke
my son passed away in
2006. so when you were in the Lakers
yeah yeah do you think that that was a
direct result of you dealing with the
pain from losing your own it could have
been
I don't know I could have been it just
probably was I just chose that time to
party
you know what I mean made the wrong
decision actually opened up a demon yeah
but I mean you know
I regret having to learn about myself in
that way I'm regret that I you know that
I had that strong
um
urge of addiction that way you feel me
you have such a hard I'm I mean that's
something that you never get over either
man losing a kid yeah no that's the
opposite of um our life cycle right we
don't think that we're supposed to
bury our children our children supposed
to bury us exactly man that's that's
tough that's definitely tough man